This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能逍遥法外。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的主持人兼治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位了解自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让一名女子怀上双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, I have a bonus episode for you guys. And if you are new around here, let me tell you about our bonus episodes. So our bonus episodes are our little shorter, sharper, more focused episodes that we do on a singular term, a singular theory, a
后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。我是杰米斯·派克，欢迎回到《你的20岁心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。今天，我为你们准备了一集特别节目。如果你是新听众，让我来介绍一下我们的特别节目。我们的特别节目是我们制作的更短、更精炼、更专注的剧集，针对一个单一的术语、一个单一的理论、一个
singular idea that you may have heard thrown around to do with psychology, to do with mental health, something that gets a lot of traction mainly online, but perhaps you never see properly discussed. This is like my chance to just dive into the research for you guys and for myself. And today we have a significant one. We are talking about the theory that depression is just a chemical in balance. Is that really true or is it a little bit too simple? A lot of how we approach depression, think about depression, is based on this biological model, but there are definitely parts of it that are no longer accurate and that we know are no longer accurate as we kind of gain, yeah, more medical understanding. So that is what we are going to talk about today. A quick disclaimer.
单一的观点，你可能听说过这些与心理学、心理健康有关的词汇，它们在网上引起了很大反响，但也许你从未见过被恰当地讨论过。这是我为你们和我自己深入研究这些研究的机会。今天我们有一个重要的议题。我们正在讨论“抑郁症仅仅是化学物质失衡”这一理论。这真的是真的吗，还是说它太简单了？我们处理抑郁症、思考抑郁症的方式很大程度上基于这种生物学模型，但其中肯定有一些部分已经不再准确，随着我们获得更多的医学理解，我们知道它们不再准确。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。一个简短的免责声明。
please do not take this as medical advice. A lot of our discussion today does have implications for things like antidepressants. I'm on antidepressants. I literally just took mine like five minutes ago. They help me. I will continue to stay on them and I do believe they work. You know, some articles that we're going to cite today are skeptical of that. But as always, you know, what works for you might not work for everyone.
请不要将其视为医疗建议。我们今天的讨论确实对诸如抗抑郁药之类的事情有影响。我正在服用抗抑郁药。我五分钟前刚吃过。它们对我有效。我将继续服用，我相信它们有效。你知道，我们今天引用的某些文章对此持怀疑态度。但一如既往，你知道，对你有效的方法可能并不适用于所有人。
if you are on antidepressants, if you are considering it, always talk to your doctor before starting or stopping this kind of medication. Just want to put that in here because, yeah, you know, this discussion does have some big implications for that and I don't want anybody to be making rash decisions around 30 minutes of audio. So with that being said, let's get into it, starting with what do we actually mean by depression is a chemical imbalance? This is a chemical imbalance. This is widely believed to be quite an outdated description actually these days, and yet it is still used all the time. But when people say this, what they actually mean is the idea that depression happens because your brain doesn't have enough of certain neurotransmitters, especially serotonin. And therefore, increasing the balance or the level of that neurotransmitter will correct.
如果你正在服用抗抑郁药，或者正在考虑服用，在开始或停止此类药物之前，请务必咨询你的医生。我只是想在这里提一下，因为，你知道，这个讨论确实对此有一些重大影响，我不希望任何人因为30分钟的音频而做出草率的决定。话虽如此，让我们开始吧，首先从我们所说的“抑郁症是化学物质失衡”到底是什么意思开始。这是一种化学失衡。实际上，如今这被广泛认为是一种相当过时的描述，但它仍然被频繁使用。但当人们这样说时，他们实际上指的是这样一种观点：抑郁症的发生是因为你的大脑中缺乏某些神经递质，尤其是血清素。因此，增加这种神经递质的平衡或水平将纠正
direct the deficiency and will eliminate depression. Neurotransmitters, just for a very quick biological refresh, are the brain's chemical messengers. Your brain cells, your neurons, they don't actually touch each other directly. They communicate across these tiny gaps to stop electrical signals from interrupting each other. And the things that pass through those gaps and pass on messages are your neurotransmitters. So they influence everything from mood to motivation, sleep, appetite, attention, stress response, everything that is going on in your body at any given moment. As I've mentioned, one transmitter you will hear constantly in these conversations is serotonin. Serotonin is a chemical messenger involved in so many processes. I think a lot of people just think of it
这种缺乏，并将消除抑郁症。神经递质，为了快速复习一下生物学知识，是大脑的化学信使。你的脑细胞，即神经元，它们实际上并不直接接触。它们通过这些微小的间隙进行交流，以防止电信号相互干扰。而穿过这些间隙并传递信息的东西就是你的神经递质。因此，它们影响着从情绪到动力、睡眠、食欲、注意力、压力反应，即你身体在任何时刻发生的一切。正如我提到的，你在这些对话中会不断听到的一个递质是血清素。血清素是一种参与许多过程的化学信使。我想很多人只是把它
as the happiness drug or the happiness chemical, but it affects everything from mood to sleep to appetite to emotional regulation, those things have a correlation with happiness, which is why, yeah, it's why it gets that simplistic definition of like, this is the happy chemical, or dopamine often gets cited as that as well for the same reasons. So this is how the biological story of depression came to be. Serotonin controls mood, mood controls happiness, depressed people are unhappy. Therefore, working in reverse, someone who is unhappy and with a low mood must have disturbances in serotonin. Therefore, artificially changing or influencing serotonin availability will improve depression, because this is, at the end of the day, just a biological shortage problem.
当作快乐药物或快乐化学物质，但它影响着从情绪到睡眠、食欲、情绪调节等方方面面，这些事情与快乐有关，这就是为什么，是的，这就是为什么它得到了“这是快乐化学物质”这种简单的定义，或者多巴胺也经常因为同样的原因被这样引用。这就是抑郁症生物学故事的由来。血清素控制情绪，情绪控制快乐，抑郁的人是不快乐的。因此，反过来推导，一个不快乐且情绪低落的人一定有血清素方面的紊乱。因此，人为地改变或影响血清素的可用性将改善抑郁症，因为归根结底，这只是一个生物学短缺问题。
When did this theory actually first come to be? Because I feel like now it's just taken for granted. I was literally, like, my dad says this all the time. time, like it's just a chemical imbalance. We just take it for granted, whether it is correct or not. To understand this, you have to look back to the 50s and 60s when there was this huge medical push to basically create a drug for every condition. And doctors started noticing during this process, kind of by accident, that certain drugs
这个理论到底是什么时候出现的？因为我觉得现在它被认为是理所当然的。我真的，比如，我爸爸总是这么说。就像这只是一种化学失衡。无论它是否正确，我们都认为它是理所当然的。要理解这一点，你必须回顾50年代和60年代，当时医学界有一股巨大的推动力，基本上是为每一种疾病创造一种药物。医生们在这个过程中偶然发现，某些药物
developed for completely different reasons were affecting mood. Drugs for, like, wart treatment. drugs for epilepsy, drugs for hair growth, just like anything you can think of. They started noticing that it was also changing how people felt. There was a really notable review paper from this man called Shinda Crout in 1965, who was kind of the first one to be like, hey, maybe this is saying something. Maybe some depressions could be linked to a deficiency in certain chemicals.
出于完全不同的原因开发的药物正在影响情绪。比如治疗疣的药物、治疗癫痫的药物、生发药物，任何你能想到的药物。他们开始注意到它也在改变人们的感觉。1965年，一位名叫辛达·克劳特的人发表了一篇非常著名的综述文章，他是第一个提出“嘿，也许这说明了什么。也许某些抑郁症可能与某些化学物质的缺乏有关”的人。
And he concluded this based on his study of animals alone. Because back then, this theory was quite an experimental one that he was doing. And also that's normally the first stage of any theory that wants to have like pharmaceutical implications, like you test on animals. But at that time, like I said, it was not controversial. It was just different. It was just a different idea. And so it led researchers to focus on one group of neurotransensual.
他得出这个结论仅仅是基于他对动物的研究。因为在当时，这个理论对他来说是一个相当实验性的理论。而且这通常是任何想要具有药物影响的理论的第一阶段，比如你在动物身上进行测试。但在当时，正如我所说，它并不具争议性。它只是不同的。它只是一个不同的想法。因此，它促使研究人员专注于一组神经递质
in particular called monoamines. Monoamine, monoamines, I should say plural, is just a class of neurotransmitters that include things like serotonin, like noraphenaphrin, and like dopamine. And they concentrated on all those as kind of one in a way. This became the monamine hypothesis. You may have heard about this, but it was basically the earliest biological theory of depression. Depression is because of a disruption in chemical messenger systems. Fast forward over a decade, I guess a decade, yeah, a decade.
特别是被称为单胺的物质。单胺，我应该说复数形式，只是一类神经递质，包括血清素、去甲肾上腺素和多巴胺等。他们把所有这些都集中在一起，视为一种东西。这就是单胺假说。你可能听说过这个，但它基本上是抑郁症最早的生物学理论。抑郁症是因为化学信使系统的中断。快进十多年，我想是十年，是的，十年。
In 1975, the first, like, big, big paper came out about a drug called fluoxetine, which is still on the market today and worked by, it works still by increasing serotonin in the brain of rats, of people by preventing the re-uptake of serotonin. So basically how our brain cleans up and gets rid of serotonin that's sitting in the synapse. That's like the simple way of putting it. This drug became so popular, so popular almost instantly, probably because like the other treatments for depression at that time were not amazing. they weren't that great.
1975年，第一篇关于一种名为氟西汀的药物的重磅论文发表了，这种药物至今仍在市场上销售，它的作用原理仍然是通过防止血清素的再摄取来增加大鼠和人体大脑中的血清素。所以基本上就是我们的大脑如何清理和清除突触中残留的血清素。这就是简单的说法。这种药物几乎立刻变得非常受欢迎，可能是因为当时抑郁症的其他治疗方法并不理想。它们没那么好。
Yeah, they just weren't, they weren't great. So Prozac, Fluoxetine, just like hit the market running. And also started being kind of like, that recommended for heaps of other things. So like, yes, major depressive disorder, but then also OCD, panic disorder, eating disorders as well, anything that people believed came down to mood
是的，它们就是不好。所以百忧解（氟西汀）一上市就大获成功。而且也开始被推荐用于许多其他事情。所以，是的，重度抑郁症，还有强迫症、恐慌症、饮食失调，任何人们认为归结为情绪的问题
and our attempts to or inability to regulate our mood or regulate things that, you know, any behaviours that we use to try and regulate our mood that were becoming problematic or whatever. Like they basically just were like, this is the one. You just, you grab,
以及我们试图调节情绪的尝试或无能，或者我们用来试图调节情绪但变得成问题的任何行为，等等。就像他们基本上只是说，这就是那个药。你只要，你抓住，
you get on this and you're going to be feeling so much better. So this is when the public narrative became that simplified version of depression is just a chemical imbalance. Because now there was this drug, this cure that could just, in their words, like eliminate all those dark, bad thoughts, like those dark bad feelings that people felt a lot of shame towards that, I guess also were, yeah, really impairing people. It all came down to this really simple equation.
你服用这个，你会感觉好多了。这就是公众叙事变成“抑郁症仅仅是化学物质失衡”这种简化版本的时候。因为现在有了这种药物，这种治愈方法，用他们的话说，可以消除所有那些黑暗、糟糕的想法，那些人们感到非常羞耻的黑暗、糟糕的感觉，这些感觉也确实在严重损害人们。这一切都归结为一个非常简单的等式。
There isn't enough of this one thing in your brain. We increase it. You will feel better. And that's really reassuring to a lot of people. And it's easy to deliver, like in a health care, perspective, you know, if you're a GP, if you're a doctor, if you're a psychologist, psychiatrist, whatever, and you've got a short amount of time with a patient, you've got a waiting room full of people who are really struggling. This idea that you can give somebody this tablet
你的大脑中缺乏这种东西。我们增加它。你会感觉更好。这对很多人来说是非常令人放心的。而且从医疗保健的角度来看，它很容易提供，你知道，如果你是一名全科医生，如果你是一名医生，如果你是一名心理学家、精神科医生，无论是什么，你和病人在一起的时间很短，你的候诊室里坐满了真正挣扎的人。这种你可以给某人这种药片
and that's going to make them feel better is a great one and is one that people really want to hang on to, obviously. A 2005 paper from researchers in the US actually later analyzed a as well, how antidepressants were marketed to the American public when they first came out. And they argued that a lot of these campaigns really pushed the use of antidepressants by basically, again, using this chemical imbalance message. And that marketing was really significant in how a whole generation and the generation after that of people, including you and me, started thinking of this, of this condition. started thinking of depression. So it wasn't plucked out of thin air, as I said. It all came down to
并且这会让他们感觉更好的想法是一个很好的想法，也是人们真正想要坚持的想法，显然。2005年，美国研究人员的一篇论文后来也分析了抗抑郁药刚上市时是如何向美国公众推销的。他们认为，许多这些运动确实通过基本上再次使用这种化学失衡的信息来推动抗抑郁药的使用。这种营销对于整整一代人以及之后的一代人，包括你和我，开始思考这种情况的方式产生了非常重大的影响。开始思考抑郁症。所以它不是凭空捏造的，正如我所说。这一切都归结为
the first really promising treatment pathway and why that treatment pathway seemed to work. And the thing is, there are literally thousands of randomized trials that show antidepressants do work. They do work. They beat a placebo on average. But the problem is it is not the miracle drug that people think it is. At least not for everyone. And the effects aren't as dramatic as maybe we've been led to believe. If we kind of average out everybody's response, and this is where the skepticism around depression is just a chemical imbalance comes in.
第一个非常有希望的治疗途径，以及为什么该治疗途径似乎有效。问题是，确实有成千上万的随机试验表明抗抑郁药确实有效。它们确实有效。平均而言，它们优于安慰剂。但问题是，它并不是人们认为的灵丹妙药。至少不是对每个人都有效。而且效果并不像我们被引导相信的那样戏剧化。如果我们把每个人的反应平均一下，这就是围绕“抑郁症仅仅是化学物质失衡”的怀疑论产生的地方。
Basically, a drug is a great safety net. It is life-changing. But depression is a three, four, five-headed monster. and taking medication only cuts off one of those heads. So our healthcare system does need to be providing more than what a biological approach would suggest. You've probably heard of this. There has been a major push recently around this prominent theory that the reason SSRI's work is basically because they are a placebo. The biological model is not correct.
基本上，药物是一个很好的安全网。它是改变生活的。但抑郁症是一个三头、四头、五头怪兽。而服用药物只能砍掉其中一个头。所以我们的医疗保健系统确实需要提供比生物学方法所建议的更多的东西。你可能听说过这个。最近有一个主要的推动力，围绕着一个突出的理论，即SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）有效的原因基本上是因为它们是安慰剂。生物学模型是不正确的。
It's just the idea that people are doing something for their mental health that improve. proves their mental health. I don't personally believe that. My thoughts about this are complicated. Let's just get into the evidence. So this theory really took the world by storm with the publication of this big paper in 2011 that seemed to conclude that in most cases, I think their estimate was like in 80% of cases, what people are experiencing when their symptoms get better by taking an SSRI is purely the belief that, again, this medication is doing something. That belief influences our perception of reality, and that perception and belief is what makes us feel better. This study, again, was massive. It did look at it so many people, but a follow-up, or I guess one, a prior review showed that it's probably a
这只是人们为自己的心理健康做了一些事情从而改善了心理健康的想法。我个人并不相信这一点。我对这个问题的看法很复杂。让我们直接进入证据。所以这个理论在2011年发表的一篇大论文中真正席卷了世界，该论文似乎得出的结论是，在大多数情况下，我想他们的估计是80%的情况下，当人们通过服用SSRI症状好转时，他们所经历的纯粹是相信这种药物正在起作用。这种信念影响了我们对现实的感知，而这种感知和信念就是让我们感觉更好的原因。这项研究再次规模巨大。它确实观察了很多人，但后续研究，或者我想说，之前的一项综述显示，情况可能
little bit different. It is not that this many people are reacting to a placebo effect. It's that the real benefit comes and the real benefit can be seen based on severity first. So basically, this FDA review found that an SSRI offers more noticeable benefits for people with more severe depression who are more likely to have a larger biological component compared to people with milder presentations who may still have a biological component, but perhaps their depression is coming down to other things. And for them, a placebo and an SSRI, you know, the fake version and the real version might impact behaviour and impact how they feel in similar ways. They also found that the reason why this is the case is because an SSRI isn't always acting directly on our
有点不同。并不是这么多人对安慰剂效应有反应。真正的益处来自于，真正的益处可以首先根据严重程度来看。所以基本上，这项FDA综述发现，SSRI对于更严重的抑郁症患者提供了更明显的益处，他们更有可能具有更大的生物学成分，而对于症状较轻的患者，他们可能仍然有生物学成分，但也许他们的抑郁症归结为其他事情。对他们来说，安慰剂和SSRI，你知道，假版本和真版本可能会以类似的方式影响行为和他们的感觉。他们还发现，之所以如此，是因为SSRI并不总是直接作用于我们的
mood. It's affecting things that are going to impact mood down the line. So another trial from 2019 shows this really well. It looked at cetraline, setterlene for depressive symptoms. And it found that in the first six weeks, like, in under six weeks, if somebody was like, I feel amazing, it probably wasn't because of an immediate biological impact on serotonin levels. it was more so because it affected how they were able to sleep. It affected a sense of control over the depressive symptoms. It affected energy levels. It affected, yeah, their mindset, especially in that first part.
情绪。它影响的是那些最终会影响情绪的事情。所以2019年的另一项试验很好地证明了这一点。它观察了舍曲林对抑郁症状的作用。它发现，在最初的六周内，比如，在六周内，如果有人说，我感觉棒极了，那可能不是因为对血清素水平的直接生物学影响。更多是因为它影响了他们的睡眠方式。它影响了对抑郁症状的控制感。它影响了能量水平。它影响了，是的，他们的心态，特别是在那最初的部分。
What this is really coming down to, like, the placebo effect, let's be real, is probably real for some people. Like, it probably is real, but not for everyone. and it's not just the placebo effect that's having an impact. That is one part of perhaps some people's experience with SSRIs, but it's also the fact that even if this drug doesn't act directly on happiness or directly on mood, it does act on all these other things that do make people feel better. And that if you have, and I hate to say like,
这真正归结为，比如，安慰剂效应，让我们面对现实吧，对某些人来说可能是真实的。就像，它可能确实是真实的，但不是对每个人。而且不仅仅是安慰剂效应在产生影响。这是某些人使用SSRIs的经历的一部分，但事实是，即使这种药物不直接作用于快乐或直接作用于情绪，它确实作用于所有其他让人们感觉更好的事情。而且如果你有，我讨厌说像，
I hate to say mild depression, but that's kind of the clinical term, if you have mild depression, right? Those things may be contributing more to your hopelessness and your sadness and your depressed state than we think. And so taking those out and influencing them is what's making us feel better. Let's discuss this a little bit more because I do have a problem with this theory. I have a big problem. Whether a drug is a placebo or not, obviously it is important because you don't want to put people on medications that are going to
我讨厌说轻度抑郁，但那是临床术语，如果你有轻度抑郁，对吧？这些事情可能比我们想象的更多地导致了你的绝望、悲伤和抑郁状态。所以消除这些因素并影响它们才是让我们感觉更好的原因。让我们多讨论一下这个问题，因为我确实对这个理论有意见。我有很大的意见。无论药物是否是安慰剂，显然这很重要，因为你不想让人们服用那些
do, that could impact them in other ways if they literally aren't impacting the primary symptom. But what I will say is that if it works for people who otherwise feel hopeless, is that really a bad thing? You know, thoughts are powerful. Taking a medication that impacts your ability to deal with your thoughts by providing you with the control mechanism is powerful. It's just another version of all these thought therapies, of all the ways that we try and change. people's thoughts to change their coping. B, my other issue with the placebo theory is that you cannot take a theory as big and large as the biological theory of depression, a theory that supports one of the first and only lines
如果它们根本没有影响主要症状，却可能以其他方式影响他们的药物。但我会说，如果它对那些原本感到绝望的人有效，那真的是一件坏事吗？你知道，思想是强大的。服用一种通过为你提供控制机制来影响你处理思想能力的药物是强大的。这只是所有这些思维疗法的另一种版本，是我们试图改变人们思想以改变他们的应对方式的所有方式。B，我对安慰剂理论的另一个问题是，你不能采取像抑郁症生物学理论这样大而广的理论，一个支持数百万数百万受苦者首选且唯一的治疗方案之一的理论。你不能采取那个理论，把它撕碎而不提供另一个。我认为这非常冷酷且不道德。这是我的观点。我认为人们太急于制造头条新闻，太急于以帮助人们为幌子去推翻一个理论，而这实际上让他们感觉更糟，对吧？最近有一股整体的推动力，这是一个合理的推动力，对吧，去质疑：生物学理论正确吗？比如，药物真的对人们有任何作用吗？
of treatment for millions of millions of people who are suffering. You cannot take that theory, tear it apart and not offer another one. I think that is deeply callous and unethical. And this is my opinion. I think people are so quick to want to make a headline, to want to disprove a theory under the guise of helping people, and it actually leaves them feeling worse, right? There has been this whole push recently, and it's a valid push, right, to be like, is the biological theory correct? Like, is medication even really doing anything for people?
比如，我们在浪费什么时间？人们非常急于说，它没有，这是我的最终结论。它只是安慰剂，把它撕成碎片，然后就像是，那你还给人们提供什么？别说运动，别说饮食。比如，你还给那些难治性抑郁症患者提供什么？或者你还给那些发现SSRIs是救命稻草的人提供什么？现在，就像，所以我不要服用这个，回到我以前的样子吗？就像我认为这是一个非常艰难的决定。对于网上的人来说也是一样，现在这个安慰剂理论已经真正站稳了脚跟，它变得更加突出，更加被接受，人们现在正在用它作为一种方式来羞辱人们的健康决定。我前几天发了那个帖子，不，不是前几天，几个月前，关于我在20多岁时服用来士普（Lexapro）是如何改变生活的，确实如此，评论区里有个女人非常激动
Like, what are we wasting our time on? And people are really quick to be like, it's not, this is my final conclusion. it's just a placebo, rip it to shreds, and it's like, so what else are you offering people? And don't say exercise, don't say diet. Like, what else are you offering people with treatment resistant depression? Or what else are you offering people who have our own SSRIs find them to be life-saving? And now, like, so do I not take this and go back to the way I was before? like I think that's I think that's a really hard call to make the same goes with people online like now that this placebo theory has really gained legs it's become a lot more prominent a lot more accepted people are now using it as a way to kind of shame people for health decisions I made this post the other day no not the other day a couple months ago about how going on lexapro in my 20s was life changing and it is and there was this woman all up in arms in my comment section
说，科学已经完全推翻了这一点。科学说这些药物对你没有任何作用。这就是为什么我永远不会服用它们。当我问她，你会建议什么替代方案时？她给了我一些非常可悲的回答，这让我非常恼火。实际上，这让我非常生气。为什么要来这里？来到我的页面，以某种方式进入我的生活，审问我的健康选择，把它们撕碎，引入一种关于对我有所帮助的事情的绝望感，然后走开，好像你帮了我一样，而没有给我提供替代方案，没有理解我的处境。就像，那是残忍的。
being like, science has completely disproved this. Science says that like these drugs aren't doing anything for you. That's why I would never take them. And when I asked her, what would you suggest instead? She gave me some really pathetic answers and it annoyed me so freaking much. Actually, it made me really mad. Why come here? Come in here to my page, into my life in a way, interrogate my health choices, rip them apart, introduce a sense of hopelessness about the thing that has helped me, and then walk out like you've helped me without providing me with an alternative, without understanding my situation. Like, that is cruel.
那是残忍的。我认为当我们去撕碎化学失衡生物学模型时，我们确实必须考虑那种影响。所以让我们在短暂休息后多谈谈这一点。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个
That is cruel. And I think when we go to tear apart the chemical imbalance biological model, we do have to think about that impact. So let's talk about that a little bit more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who, take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2% I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our
奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们真的相信。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。
strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We really believe. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代的快克可卡因。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black. people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where
我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我不认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。
we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候已经足够了，因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得作为一个好人很重要吗？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself, at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
我伪造了一次检测。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。就像我被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的惩罚。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。一旦化学失衡
podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Once the chemical imbalance
的言论成为主导故事。它不仅改变了科学研究的头条新闻，还改变了人们理解自己的方式，家庭对诊断的反应，医疗保健系统治疗抑郁症的方式，这确实是非常、非常积极的。对很多人来说，化学失衡的框架让抑郁症终于感觉合法了。如果你在一种认为心理健康是多余的、关注它是一种放纵的社会叙事中长大，那么听到抑郁症与我们字面上的大脑化学物质有关，会是非常有力的验证。它通过让你知道你在身体层面上确实不健康，带来了一种解脱感。它还减少了这种古老的指责感。
rhetoric became the dominant story. It not only changed like scientific research headlines, it also changed how people understood themselves, how families responded to diagnosis, how the healthcare system treated depression, and that has been really, really positive. For a lot of people, the chemical imbalance framing made depression finally feel legitimate. If you grew up with a societal narrative that mental health was superfluous, it was an indulgent thing to pay attention to, then hearing that, you know, depression has links to our literal brain chemistry can be immensely validating. And it brings a sense of relief by knowing you are actually unwell in a physical sense. It also reduces this like age-old sense of blame.
抑郁症是你的一种选择。你可以摆脱它。这种模型，如何让人们意识到情况并非如此？你不能进入你的大脑
That depression is something that you can choose. You can snap out of it. This model, how would people realize that that is not the case? You cannot go into your brain. and change chemical messaging. Like that's not something that you're able to do. You were born this way. This is just who you are. So on a human level, like this story, this chemical imbalance story, gave people a bridge, gave people a language for suffering and for their condition
并改变化学信息传递。那不是你能做到的事情。你是天生如此。这就是你。所以在人类层面上，这个故事，这个化学失衡的故事，给了人们一座桥梁，给了人们一种语言来描述痛苦和他们的状况
that others could understand. And it also made medication and it made treatment feel less scary. It brought a lot of people out of the dark, a lot of people out of the, the, you know, the hiding spaces of shame and said, we can help you. We can help you. This isn't your fault. And that has reduced stigma greatly. It's been an incredibly positive thing. There are some trade-offs, though. As much as I don't like the placebo idea, I also think the purely biological, I don't know, I don't want to say mindset, approach, belief, hypothesis is also incorrect. And the reason I think it's problematic is because it's reduced a very huge complex
其他人也能理解。它也让药物和治疗感觉不那么可怕。它把很多人从黑暗中带了出来，把很多人从羞耻的藏身之处带了出来，并说，我们可以帮助你。我们可以帮助你。这不是你的错。这极大地减少了污名化。这是一件非常积极的事情。不过，也有一些权衡。尽管我不喜欢安慰剂的想法，但我认为纯粹的生物学，我不知道，我不想说心态、方法、信念、假设也是不正确的。我认为它有问题的原因是，它把一个非常巨大、复杂的
condition into a single simplistic explanation, which actually shrank and it continues to shrink down the magnitude of people's experience with it. In a way, it confuses what the treatment changes with what caused the problem in the first place. SSRIs change serotonin signaling. That's true. but saying SSRIs affect serotonin because serotonin is the reason that you are depressed is not entirely accurate. Just in the same way as paracetamol helps a headache, but it's not a lack of paracetamol that causes the headache is also true. It might be, you know, you need paracetamol, you have a headache because you're ill, because you didn't drink enough water, because you're hung over. The paracetamol still helps. the origin of the symptom isn't the lack of paracetamol.
状况简化为一个单一的简单解释，这实际上缩小了，并且继续缩小了人们经历它的程度。在某种程度上，它混淆了治疗改变的东西与导致问题的根本原因。SSRIs改变了血清素信号。这是真的。但说SSRIs影响血清素是因为血清素是你抑郁的原因并不完全准确。就像扑热息痛有助于缓解头痛，但并不是缺乏扑热息痛导致了头痛一样。可能是，你知道，你需要扑热息痛，你头痛是因为你生病了，因为你喝水不够，因为你宿醉了。扑热息痛仍然有帮助。症状的起源并不是缺乏扑热息痛。
The same way the origin of symptoms may not be just a lack of serotonin. A lot of treatments work by compensating for symptoms rather than getting down to the underlying issue. And there are a lot of people who are depressed not because of brain chemistry or because brain chemistry and then a bunch of other stuff on top of that. But it's not just this biological thing. It's an interplay of grief, trauma, loneliness, burnout, chronic stress, poverty, discrimination, life events, you know, a relationship that flawed them, a life without rest, a job hunting process that's been really terrible. The chemical imbalance story can sometimes make those factors feel irrelevant and say like, oh, if we get you on this antidepressant, you will feel better.
同样，症状的起源可能不仅仅是缺乏血清素。许多治疗方法通过补偿症状而不是解决根本问题来发挥作用。有很多人抑郁不是因为大脑化学物质，或者因为大脑化学物质加上其他一堆东西。但这不仅仅是生物学上的事情。它是悲伤、创伤、孤独、倦怠、慢性压力、贫困、歧视、生活事件、一段让他们崩溃的关系、没有休息的生活、非常糟糕的求职过程的相互作用。化学失衡的故事有时会让这些因素感觉无关紧要，并说，哦，如果我们让你服用这种抗抑郁药，你会感觉更好。
And sometimes that's why they don't work, because they cannot fix what lives outside the bloodstream. Medication can definitely reduce symptoms, mood, anxiety, agitation, sleep, appetite, concentration, those sort of things. But it doesn't actually repair financial pressures, caregiving pressures, academic stress, workplace drama, loneliness, disconnection, an unhappy, unsafe relationship, a life that feels meaningless, people treating you badly in society. How can we claim that a tablet can fix all of that and call it a day? We can't. It just can't. It can help you with coping. It doesn't change what physically surrounds you. You know, sometimes depression is a signal that something isn't working in your life. And it cannot reduce those physical circumstances if those are the cause. And And I say if, because yes, the biological model is valid on some front.
有时这就是它们不起作用的原因，因为它们无法修复血液循环之外的东西。药物肯定可以减轻症状，情绪、焦虑、烦躁、睡眠、食欲、注意力等。但它并不能真正修复经济压力、护理压力、学业压力、职场戏剧、孤独、脱节、一段不快乐、不安全的关系、一种感觉毫无意义的生活、社会上人们对你的恶劣对待。我们怎么能声称一片药片就能解决所有这些问题并就此了事呢？我们不能。它就是不能。它可以帮助你应对。它不会改变你身体周围的环境。你知道，有时抑郁是一种信号，表明你的生活中有些事情行不通。如果这些是原因，它无法减少这些身体状况。而且我说是“如果”，因为是的，生物学模型在某些方面是有效的。
But when we talk about another theory that probably makes more sense, right, that theory that I was waiting for people to offer, I would say a social and development theory mixed with the biological theory is probably more accurate. You know, the interpersonal model, cognitive models, which say that our, you know, the conditions that we have, are shaped by our risk over time and by our internal and external environment over time. So yes, we have a biological vulnerability, but then include the fact that you were hurt as a child.
但当我们谈论另一个可能更有意义的理论时，对吧，那个我一直在等待人们提供的理论，我会说社会和发展理论与生物学理论相结合可能更准确。你知道，人际模型、认知模型，它们说我们的状况是随着时间的推移，由我们的风险以及我们的内部和外部环境随着时间的推移而形成的。所以是的，我们有生物学上的脆弱性，但还要加上你小时候受过伤害的事实。
Then you had inconsistent parenting. Then you had you experienced violence or you were cheated on. Then you couldn't find a job. Then you really struggled at uni, at work. Then you felt purposeless on top of all of that. Plus you're broke. Again, like that's not just biology. You cannot medicate your way out of structural stress.
接着你经历了不一致的教养方式。接着你经历了暴力，或者被背叛。接着你找不到工作。接着你在大学、工作中挣扎。接着在这一切之上，你感到毫无目标。再加上你身无分文。再说一次，这不仅仅是生物学问题。你无法通过药物治疗来摆脱结构性压力。
We need to be focusing on that as well. And we also need to be focusing on even further research that talks about how a lot of people in modern day society lack a sense of purpose, the way that they used to really have in what they were doing, in how they were living, in their free time. There was a 2023 meta-analysis that found greater purpose in life is significantly associated with lower depression and anxiety levels. Having a sense that, like, you mean something is incredibly influential in how we feel.
我们需要关注这一点。我们还需要关注更深入的研究，这些研究探讨了现代社会中许多人如何缺乏一种目标感，而这种目标感在他们过去所做的事情、生活方式以及业余时间中是真实存在的。2023年的一项荟萃分析发现，更强的人生目标感与更低的抑郁和焦虑水平显著相关。拥有一种“你很重要”的感觉，对我们的感受有着极其深远的影响。
And I think in today's age, like, it's harder to feel like you actually do mean something. You know, it's harder to feel like you're going to find a job that you really can give back in. It's hard to feel like you're going to make an impact when the world feels really terrible. So we do need to look more broadly. There's this really interesting book I read from Johann Hari called, lost connections, and he looks at this idea. His central argument is because the story of a chemical imbalance is so simple and easy to understand, it's meant that we've underpaid attention to the ways that modern life disconnects us from what we as humans need. And he frames many of the
我认为在当今时代，想要感觉到自己确实很重要变得更难了。你知道，很难感觉到你能找到一份真正能回馈社会的工作。当世界感觉非常糟糕时，很难感觉到你能产生什么影响。所以我们需要看得更广。我读过约翰·哈里（Johann Hari）写的一本非常有趣的书，叫《失落的联系》（Lost Connections），他探讨了这个观点。他的核心论点是，因为“化学失衡”的说法太简单、太容易理解，这意味着我们忽视了现代生活将我们与人类基本需求隔离开来的方式。他将许多
drivers of depression and anxiety as basically different forms of disconnection, not just biological vulnerabilities. You know, we are disconnected from nature. We are disconnected from meaningful work. We are disconnected from people, from our communities, from a meaningful future. That is having a real life impact. With this perspective, I think depression gets the complexity it deserves, whilst also acknowledging how medication is a valuable part of that. If we do not also look outside of our own brains at the world we are living in and acknowledge how it's that is probably making us feel terrible, the blame does start to come back, right? It does start to feel like, as well, our depression becomes treatment resistant. Like, we are taking the medication, we are
抑郁和焦虑的驱动因素归结为不同形式的疏离，而不仅仅是生物学上的脆弱性。你知道，我们与自然疏离了。我们与有意义的工作疏离了。我们与人、与社区、与有意义的未来疏离了。这正在产生现实的影响。有了这个视角，我认为抑郁症得到了它应有的复杂性，同时也承认药物治疗是其中的重要组成部分。如果我们不把目光投向大脑之外，看看我们所处的世界，并承认正是这些东西可能让我们感觉糟糕，那么指责就会开始回归，对吧？这确实开始让人觉得，我们的抑郁症变得难以治疗。就像我们正在服用药物，我们正在
subscribing to the biological model, and, you know, it's not working. And so maybe I am to blame, maybe this is a permanent state of being. Maybe I'm a much harder case that, and anybody has ever seen before when actually it's just that people are looking at your case or you are looking at your circumstances through a narrow lens and other things, other levers in your life could be pulled, could be readjusted so that you are happier. Like I've definitely found this since moving to London. Like my dosage of my antidepressant has stayed the same. But it looks like it's not working because I've become a lot sadder and meaner and shorter and agitated
认同生物学模型，但你知道，它不起作用。所以也许是我该被指责，也许这是一种永久的状态。也许我是一个比任何人见过的都更棘手的病例，而实际上，这只是因为人们在用狭隘的眼光看待你的情况，或者你自己在用狭隘的眼光看待你的处境，而你生活中其他的东西、其他的杠杆是可以被拉动、被重新调整的，这样你就会更快乐。自从搬到伦敦后，我肯定发现了这一点。我的抗抑郁药剂量保持不变。但看起来它不起作用了，因为我变得更加悲伤、刻薄、急躁和焦虑了，
just because now I'm living in an environment that makes me feel less and less seen and more and more, like, stressed out. Again, I don't want this to come through as though medication is the wrong thing to do. That's actually not what I think. But I do think it is a medical disservice to give someone a prescription to a drug that is really hard to come off of that does change things like your sex drive, like your weight, like your sleep, like your dreams, your energy. and not maybe, just maybe, look at some other factors and search for something else first. So what do we do with all this information? One of the main takeaways I want to leave you with is that depression is as unique as we are.
仅仅是因为我现在生活在一个让我感觉越来越不被看见，且越来越感到压力的环境中。再说一次，我不想让这听起来好像药物治疗是错误的做法。那其实不是我的想法。但我确实认为，给某人开一种很难停药、会改变性欲、体重、睡眠、梦境和精力等方面的药物，却不去——也许只是也许——看看其他因素并先寻找其他方法，这是一种医疗上的失职。那么我们该如何处理所有这些信息呢？我想留给你们的主要结论之一是，抑郁症和我们每个人一样独特。
It is a label for a cluster of symptoms and people can end up in a depressed state through totally different pathways through grief, trauma, loneliness, illness, discrimination, loss of meaning, chronic stress, often a mix of several, and then maybe also a biological component. That's why a one-size-fits-all explanation never really works. There is an infinite number of combinations of biological and environmental and psychological factors that all come together to create this experience. That's why two people can go through the same thing, beyond the same medications even, have totally different outcomes. And why the neat explanation, any narrative that wants a simple phrase to explain this probably won't work.
它是一组症状的标签，人们可以通过完全不同的途径陷入抑郁状态：通过悲伤、创伤、孤独、疾病、歧视、失去意义、慢性压力，通常是几种因素的混合，然后可能还有生物学成分。这就是为什么“一刀切”的解释从来都不真正有效。生物、环境和心理因素有无数种组合，共同创造了这种体验。这就是为什么两个人可以经历同样的事情，甚至服用同样的药物，却有完全不同的结果。这就是为什么那种简洁的解释，任何想要用简单短语来解释这一点的叙述，可能都不会奏效。
I think instead of hunting for these single cause that makes people depressed, these single cause that is easy to digest, we recognize how complex this is, we focus on reducing stress where possible, rebuilding protective connections to people, to purpose, to safety, to community, finding emotional outlets that work for us, increasing coping skills in children, finding play and joy, strengthening the parts of you that are vulnerable through therapy, through skills, through routine, and then allowing medication to remain as the sidekick, not the star of the show. And I think that that would allow people to just feel more seen. I think would also allow people to just get better in a way that is more sustainable and holistic
我认为，与其寻找导致人们抑郁的单一原因，寻找那种容易消化的单一原因，我们应该认识到这有多复杂，我们应该专注于尽可能减少压力，重建与人、与目标、与安全感、与社区的保护性联系，找到适合我们的情感宣泄渠道，提高儿童的应对技能，寻找玩耍和快乐，通过治疗、技能、日常习惯来加强你脆弱的部分，然后让药物作为配角，而不是主角。我认为这将使人们感到更被看见。我认为这也将使人们以一种更可持续、更全面
and meaningful. So there we go. That's how I'm going to wrap up the episode. I know I said at the start like this is going to be a short bonus episode obviously that is not the case. I have a lot to say about this topic and honestly even as I'm wrapping up I'm like oh I didn't even mention this I didn't mention that but yeah I want to keep it short and sweet for you guys I hope that this episode even if you didn't agree with everything I said I'm sure that's going to be some of you like it just spurred conversation honestly people in either camp stick to their guns very strongly so it is this interesting thing where like the answer you go looking for as the one that you will probably find because there is actually a lot of evidence
且更有意义的方式好起来。好了，这就是我总结本集的方式。我知道我在开头说这会是一集简短的特别节目，显然事实并非如此。关于这个话题我有很多话要说，老实说，即使在总结时，我也在想“哦，我甚至没提到这个，没提到那个”，但是的，我想为你们保持简短精炼。我希望这一集，即使你不同意我所说的一切——我相信你们中会有一些人这样——它只是引发了对话。老实说，两个阵营的人都非常坚持自己的立场，所以这是一件有趣的事情，你寻找的答案很可能就是你会找到的答案，因为实际上有很多证据
for both. But you are still free to form your own opinion based on what works for you. Honestly, at the end of the day, whatever works for you if a biological model really works for you, and that's like, it just is something to tell yourself, honestly, who cares what the evidence is? Keep it up. Keep that explanation going in your mind. You know, really, if that is the thing that's making you feel better. I really don't see a problem with that. So yeah, I hope you enjoyed the episode. Thank you as always to our researcher. Libby Colbert for her assistance with this episode. If you do not know, you can actually go and watch full episodes of the podcast. Not this episode, though, because this was a special bonus episode, but other episodes of the podcast in video format
支持两者。但你仍然可以根据什么对你有效来形成自己的观点。老实说，归根结底，无论什么对你有效，如果生物学模型真的对你有效，并且那只是告诉自己的一件事，老实说，证据是什么又有什么关系呢？坚持下去。在你的脑海中保持那种解释。你知道，如果那确实是让你感觉更好的东西，我真的没觉得有什么问题。所以，是的，希望你喜欢这一集。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本集的协助。如果你不知道，你其实可以去观看播客的完整剧集。不过不是这一集，因为这是特别节目，但播客的其他剧集有视频格式，
on Netflix. That's right. You can watch this show on Netflix. You can go there right now and check it out. You can prove me right, prove me wrong. Also, you can follow us on substack. You can follow us on Instagram if you want to connect in other ways. Instagram is a really great place to contribute to future episodes like this one. If that's something that you would like to do and also to give feedback to keep the conversation going and, yeah, to share your own lived experience. If this is something that you've been through, I always love hearing from you guys. I love hearing from the listeners.
在Netflix上。没错。你可以在Netflix上观看这个节目。你现在就可以去看看。你可以证明我是对的，也可以证明我是错的。此外，你可以在Substack上关注我们。如果你想通过其他方式联系，可以关注我们的Instagram。Instagram是一个贡献未来剧集（像这一集一样）的好地方。如果这是你想做的事情，也可以提供反馈以保持对话的进行，并且，是的，分享你自己的生活经历。如果这是你经历过的事情，我总是喜欢听你们说。我喜欢听听众们的声音。
so I will hopefully see you over there. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
所以我希望能在那里见到你们。但在此之前，请保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就是TWO%。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girls. Friends. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。朋友们。收听《Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是山姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild... I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的……我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。